Lady Gaga was on Saturday Night Live
again she's been on there before and uh
there was a skit done this just dropped
yesterday on Saturday night Live's
official YouTube channel and I want to I
want to show you this because this
was pretty shocking like I said it's
hard to be shocked anymore because it's
like the same stuff all the time but if
you didn't know this happened this is
going to be a shock for you in this skit
it's a 5 minute skit with Lady Gaga and
some friends are at a restaurant called
friendlies and in the skit one of the
friends says hey I told the host that it
was your birthday today so they're going
to come over and sing Happy Birthday and
she's like oh I don't
know uh I don't know if I feel right
about lying like that you know and
they're just like man it's okay we we're
gonna get a free ice cream Sunday so
here's where you see the crew coming to
sing to her but first they're
questioning her they're like is it
really your birthday and she and that
her friend says it is it's her birthday
and then they're like do you swear and
they start sounding demonic like
demonically possessed swear
it swear it see so they're like do you
swear it's your birthday and she's like
uhh I don't know and you hear the laugh
track everybody's like ha it takes a
turn for the worst like what in the
world does this scene you know you hear
laughing and people are eating together
for a birthday and there's some people
coming to sing and to give them a free
ice cream what what kind of turn and
twist and turn do you think this could
take look right now they're like
pointing and screaming in her
face calling her a
sinner and they're bringing in a snake
what the hell is happening I told you we
should have Li and so all the lights are
turning red there's tribal drums beating
and her friends right now they're acting
scared but here in a second they're just
going to be like whatever it it's all
good like drink the blood ultimate price
sin sin sin so they're calling her a
sinner for lying and they're all wearing
red robes this is occult ritual 101 this
is Satanic ritual abuse if you've never
heard of Sr this is a real thing this is
nothing that's a joke it's nothing funny
if it was a bunch of racist jokes
uh it would be canceled right because we
don't make fun of things that are
sensitive topics we don't take lightly
things that are offensive right
especially in today's culture like this
is the Karen culture this is the woke
culture this is where everyone's
offended by everything right cancel
culture but when it comes to mocking
Christianity Christ himself God or
glorifying Satan or the occult it's
funny right let's just laugh about it
let's put a laugh track this is
brainwashing they've been doing this for
years and years to way back when when
people would get hurt they'd play a
laugh track so now it's funny when
people get hurt right and this is
brainwashing this is where you get shows
like jackass and stuff where guys are
purposely hurting themselves and it's
funny to desensitize us that seeing
people in pain you're supposed to
sympathize with that not laugh at it and
when it comes to this
topic Satan is not a joke the occult is
not a joke it's real and so you get
these companies like cracked who release
magaz or these magazines and websites
that say uh SNL and Lady Gaga Just
kickstarted Another satanic Panic if you
don't know what satanic Panic is it's
basically like calling someone a
conspiracy theorist like if you question
things if you question the mainstream
media which we know is controlled and
it's propaganda if you question the
government who's never been trustworthy
who's never been for the people who have
always robbed people even back in jesus'
time who've always killed people I mean
when was our government trustworthy was
it Pharaoh was it Hitler was it Stalin
which one was it so if you question that
Authority you're a conspiracy theorist
and if you see what your eyes see if you
look and see this is making a light of
Satanic ritual abuse oh satanic Panic oh
it's not real bro it's a joke get over
it man why you so offended well why are
you so offended about a joke about a
homosexual or something this is where
cancel culture has come into play uh
Saturday Night Live this is their
official post on X it says never lie
about a birthday and and it's saying uh
after the episode aired a number of
people on social media suggested that
this one sketch was EV EV that Lady Gaga
and SNL staff are really devil
worshippers who aren't even trying to
hide it anymore and they're acting like
oh it's just this one sketch one sketch
really uh Lady Gaga has a reputation of
throwing up Satanic hand symbols her
music videos super occultic and
blasphemous with songs like Judas you
know look at this as above so below oh I
wonder why we think Lady Gaga is satanic
when she's openly telling you she's
literally showing you through the
symbols through the words and her songs
through her artwork through music videos
and it's not just oh a little skit you
guys are going to jump to conclusions
because of a little skit and guess what
Saturday Night Live isn't innocent
either Saturday live who had Satan lap
dancing on
Jesus uh they make fun of the church
lady she's the church lady oh could it
be Satan you know everything Satan's
hiding under a rock look at lady God
this was in Hindustan times this is just
one of the newspaper articles I found
and it says that she stayed at a hotel
and it says the hotel staff at the Plush
InterContinental Hotel in London were
shocked when they went to clean Gaga's
room and found blood in the bath however
the red substance has not has not been
identified as blood says the tabloids
reports Lady Gaga is believed to be
terrified of evil spirits and reportedly
has every hotel and tour venue scanned
by a team of paranormal investigators
before she stays there why do you think
that she's so terrified of demons
because she's messing around with the
occult and she has demonic interactions
and encounters why would you have
paranormal team check out a room every
time before you get in because you're
paranoid of the demons that you're
Conjuring up every time you perform a
Satanic ritual on stage and call it a
concert here we see her with Marina
Abramovic who is a witch and has dealt
with all kinds of celebrities and here
you see Lady Gaga with her a lot Gaga
with Abramovic during the Fashion Week
2016 here she is with a mockup they say
it's a a mockup cannibal cake who in the
right mind would do this who in their
right nons satanic mind would eat a cake
that looks like a human being and she's
not the only one there's a lot of
celebrities that go to these parties and
do this this is a common occurrence in
Hollywood so is it really just a little
skit that has people jump to conclusions
and oh satanic Panic no she's been
putting stuff out like this in her music
videos for years what is abracadabra
it's a spell I mean she's literally
making songs about witchcraft spells
Spirit cooking is what this is called
when they eat these cakes that look like
human beings dipped in a vat of blood
and here's the lady that she was
with and you see all the all the elites
that hang out with
her this lady is
sick this
1997 this is supposed to be
art mix fresh breast milk
with I mean you get the
idea this is supposed to To Be Blood on
the
walls I mean she looks like Alistar
Crowley's sister
basically so yeah this is this is not
normal this is not sane Behavior this is
openly satanic stuff and it's like
people want to Mock and ridicule you for
calling out what it is um there's
something called aam's razor you ever
heard this term the definition is the
principle that in in explaining a thing
no more assumptions should be made than
necessary the principle is often in
invoked to defend
reductionism or nominalism so the idea
is you're going by what the evidence
tells you and you're not trying to read
between the lines and make something out
of nothing you're going by what's there
and so when we see this repetitious
thing over and over and over like Lady
Gaga constantly making uh satanic
symbols and hand signs and music videos
called Judas and all these things and
even Saturday Night Live doing church
lady we see here the church lady and all
these satanic things it's not just one
thing we're not jumping to conclusions
and this is nothing to joke about
nothing to laugh about I I can't believe
that this is even a supposed comedy skit
where they're literally dressed like
Fallen Angels wearing
pentagrams and Conjuring up demons like
they're literally chanting calling a
demon's name and summoning him to punish
her for lying about her birthday once
these demons come out Lady Gaga has a
cauldron of blood and she's making her
drink it making her drink the blood this
lady starts talking and blood flows out
of her mouth and everybody laughs as
soon as her mouth opens look at
this's the J the like sat Night Live
when went all out on this skit that door
that wall back there is a revolving door
that turns into this giant skull with
illuminated eyes like they really
invested a lot for this five minute
skit and they put her in a cage tie her
up she's got blood all over because
she's been drinking
blood they rip her heart out you see it
in this guy's hand back here he's got
her heart in his hand it does You Don't
See it coming out of her but she
literally says he ripped my heart out
and then they serve the heart as an ice
cream sunde to her friends and the
friends are all happy they get to eat
her heart but her heart is on the
house a look they put a little ice cream
cone hat on Jenny's heart they are
friendly
yay I hope you guys are disturbed by
this this is disturbing look I have a
sense of humor there's nothing about
this that should be comical like I said
this people have really suffered they've
had their lives ruined and sometimes
their lives taken and sacrificed by
people like this why would you turn this
into a a comedy it'd be like turning um
Hitler annihilating Jews and putting a
laugh track on it nobody in the right
mind would do that it would be canceled
in an instant but anytime it comes to
the Bible or anything related to the
Bible it's okay you get a free pass go
ahead and make fun of him all day long
you can't make fun of Muhammad you can't
make fun of uh Jews or or Muslims but
Christianity go for it mock away and
this is the world we're in and it's
Bible prophecy coming true let me show
you some scriptures here because in
Revelation 2211 it says he that is
unjust let him be unjust still and he
which is filthy let him be filthy still
and he that is righteous let him be
righteous still and he that is Holy let
him be holy still we are racing to a
time where the line is drawn in the sand
God says enough is enough I'm sick of
this I'm sending my son to return and to
to end this thing and where you are at
in that moment whether you're laughing
at this this uh satanic stuff or whether
you're surrendering your life to God let
him who is unjust stay unjust there
comes a time when you can no longer
repent anymore and when Christ Returns
His reward is coming with him to those
who done righteously they get eternal
life to those who live according to the
lust of the Flesh and the things of this
world Eternal damnation and that time is
coming soon I believe Jesus is coming
soon look at the signs of the times look
at what we just watched and look at this
Bible verse in Isaiah 520 woe unto them
that call evil good and call good evil
and put Darkness for light and light for
darkness and put bitter for sweet and
Sweet for bitter like we are living in a
time where if you call this out if you
call the kettle black if you call it out
for what it is you just don't have a
sense of humor you're some religious
zealot you're oh satanic Panic
conspiracy
theorist this is
reality and it's not a joke and Jesus
coming soon and my prayer is that we all
be ready when he comes I don't want to
spend my life right now playing around
on the fence one foot in the world one
foot in the church messing around with
sin I want to spend the rest of my life
these last short years being a witness
for God being a light in this dark dark
world and expanding the kingdom when he
comes so all of this can end and we can
live in a perfect world with no more
pain no more sorrow nothing but peace
Joy love and all those things and I
cannot wait for it if this was shocking
to you if this was eye opening to you
please tell us about it in the comment
if you think this is satanic Panic tell
us in the comment give this video a
thumbs up or a thumbs down either way it
helps the algorithm subscribe to this
channel if you're new click the
notification Bell if you want to support
this ministry you can do so by going to
candid truth.org we have cash app PayPal
vinmo zel and also we have T-shirts if
you like t-shirts you can buy ones like
the one I'm wearing right here that says
love is kind this this is the type of
stuff we should be focused on love love
is the whole of the law we love you guys
we cannot do this without you we stepped
away in faith to start this ministry
eight months ago and God has been
working through people like you and we
cannot thank you guys enough we love you
we thank you we'll see you next time God
bless